ready facepalm I'm in a mood to facepalm
let's go Japanese woman is accused of
appropriating her own culture why the
Frick are you and other white chick
wearing kimonos you white people need to
stop taking Japanese culture also you
two look horrible in kimonos it doesn't
even match you
it's yukata not the kimono and also I
have Japanese Passport get on I don't
know this does not make me face pal
a person infected with measles went to
Portland Trail Blazers game last week
and cut 22 oh god I genuinely faceball
that's epic 22 people in fact then oh
stop this is where the government needs
to step in and just vaccinate everyone
what are they gonna do next but ship in
their hands government stay out you're
standing right in front of the best
example in the whole world that proves
that walls don't work at the Berlin Wall
last week walls work Oh God officials
trick-or-treaters beware marijuana candy
edibles absolutely no one in the planet
will give away their animals for free to
your children please go big brain time
Gotham atheist if God isn't real
how do you explain walking on the water
can be welcome what they're like Jesus
yes show me a video of you walking on
water I don't need to you just need to
have faith that I did I don't know what
I would consider myself religiously but
regardless the whole atheist calling out
religious people is so [ __ ] cringe oh
yeah there's no God then take your
fedora and eat it I don't want to hear
it if you are white and can't speak
Spanish are you familiar with the entire
country have cultural appropriation pain
stop it stop it Spain cultural
appropriation is one of the concepts
that I will refuse to accept ever to be
a thing we should have just thrown it
out right away
what makes the world beautiful is the
fact that we can not steal from cultures
but appreciate other cultures and even
me then what's the problem we're one
nation
oh but historically whites would take
part yeah but that's
not that's not the case 99% of the time
ok just remember for every boomer that
hates a millennial there's a generation
in between the hate SIBO oh my god it's
me that's right this movie was expressly
about not generalizing and judging but
you I don't know what movie this is
Florida abortion bill would require a
judge to rule if teens mature enough to
terminate pregnancy sure let's give her
child there you go you're not mature
enough to not have a child
wait what that world is so strange isn't
it
you're not the mature enough to not have
a child I should read some being fired
if you don't trust science behind your
chosen career find another career I'm
healthy I declined flu flu vaccine so
I'm being shamed Oh God
flu vaccines aren't really a thing here
in Europe I don't think you have to get
vaccinated for every flu that seems kind
of stupid to be honest separating from
vaccinations I think it's very different
why don't you MERS have a specific noise
that means there are bees here let's
leave immediately why are elephant's
more advanced in us we do have a
specific noise it sounds like this there
are bees here let's go you hear those
beef sounds that means let's get out of
here like an elephant communicate this
why is there no flat Mars Society hi
Ellen thanks for a question unlike Earth
Mars have been absurd to be around we
hope you have a fantastic day - shut the
[ __ ] up I'm so sick of hearing my flight
earthling nurse woman claims that her
dog turned vegetarian and didn't crave
meat anymore dog proves her stupidity oh
wow it's the hip it's got to be this
fake vegan meat this is in white robust
our racist have you ever noticed the
popularity of white robots the reason
for these shades of technology Oh white
maybe raises him according to new
research
thank you for absolutely nothing we're
at CNN I swear it i sweared the whole
business models of modern day media it's
just let's write something [ __ ]
[ __ ] and then enough people will
tell us we're idiots that's how they are
in business at this point ha ha I read
this a yr Nintendo code so long guys my
code does network anymore
Kirill the why are they so long the
elevator doors open up and that guy
walked in the elevator it was just me
and him there and he said I love you and
I'm not rude so I said I love you too he
gave me a weird looking pointed at his
Bluetooth you should have pointed at
your ear as well and be like yeah I'm
doing the same all right I don't
actually love you oh cool all this
there's a lot of anti backs here my own
vex toddler and I have a whooping cough
I feel so guilty
like could I have prevented this oh my
god yes but my child has autism now poof
it has autism found a job opening that
requires for eight plus years of Swift
experience Swift is programming language
that kima three years ago this is the
equivalent of me you need their job to
have work experience but you need
experience to have job that's exactly
what I meant to say the world's richest
country came up with just 22 million to
fight the Amazon fires Stewart little
little budget 103 billion oh yeah
what was the return of that oh yeah now
that's an investment in the 1980s AMW
tried to compete with my there with a
McDonald's quarter pounder by selling a
third pound burger at a lower cost the
product failed because most customers
thought 1/4 pan was bigger but the
number is lower bigger brain it's hard
oh that's so funny someone should make a
fifth pound burger or I can give you a
tenth pound burger that's a lot of
burger kids these days have it a lot
easier than we did growing up that's the
goal though right isn't that the point
is the Boomer scenario just summarized
beautifully how dare these kids have it
easier a guy says he was questioned on a
plane for doing math during a flight a
woman sitting next to the Ivy League
economist told a flight crew
she had security concerns about them man
Oh God face palming begins after seeing
him right in a foreign script it turned
out to be differential equation it must
be some sort of terrorist language Oh
security imagine just glancing over at
your flights just calm down and tell
security if your social security number
was the amount of money you had Oh God
I really would to be I feel like this
can't be real though are people that
stupid definitely 100% they are CNN
legal analyst Arriva Martin accuses
David Webb of white privilege before
learning he Oh God we live in a society
society that is so fun stupid where
people always is dumb how about people
always been so dumb it's like it just
feels like current politics is so at an
all-time high down why I stopped
watching Nigerian movies a man had a
heart attack in the hospital and the
doctor shouted somebody call an
ambulance
you just described to me a reason to
watch Nigerian movies that sounds
awesome
author ask wise book called no more
plastic was wrapped in plastic oh that's
gonna hurt so hard I know they rap books
just to make sure people don't read in
them but that's kind of unusual to do
choose wisely Apple Proust and one plus
sixty Nintendo switch for games Amazon
fire a year of Netflix if you buy the
Apple Proust and I can guarantee you
that you already have these things right
it doesn't really make any sense like it
is a luxury product clearly that does
not mean it's for everyone
I'm face-palming about this for the
wrong reason call the restaurant to make
a reservation but couldn't think of the
word so I asked for a food appointment
and now I can never show my face there
again I feel like I can't relate to this
so many times when I make a call I just
never know
I never prepare what I'm
about to saying as soon as I'm there
like I need to put appointment yeah I
could see this happening gosh that's
awful
Scizor hair action can i book is that
scissor hair remove whoa please oh I
wanted to do a video on this video but I
know Ellen clips gets copyrighted it's
so painful to watch cuz it's like can
this teenager use a rotary phone in a
sense it's just tongue-in-cheek
it doesn't mean anything but it's such a
dumb example of like trying to make kids
look stupid meanwhile they can't figure
out how to change the HDMI on your
remote control don't get me wrong kids
very dumb very dumb me very big brain
being faithful in a relationship should
be done without being asked hate when
people are like when he's faithful like
didn't you cheat on my boy Nick do
delete that place that's not cool that
is so not cool if I ever become
president I will ban social media
because I'm sick and tired of everyone
saying she Twitter has made it in face
we has made it too comfortable to write
dumb comments that no one wants to hear
she claims they deliver leave after
barbecue meat smell into her yard vegan
takes her neighbor's to court to stop
them from cooking me isn't this the one
where they lost and they had a big
barbeque party afterwards gonna be so
annoying when I was six my sister was
half my age nam cemani how old's my
sister 35 let's have a hard one next
time please wait what what's the dumbest
thing you have ever heard I Drive for
uber on the weekends and one time a girl
who was in her late twenties told me
that I was making her uncomfortable I
hadn't said a word the whole trip so I
asked how could I make the situation
better she said she didn't like how I
kept playing with the fidget stick in
the middle of the car I Drive a menu she
then told me that I didn't need to use
that because her car didn't have that
and claimed to be a mechanic why we how
does that even make you uncomfortable
why does that make you uncomfortable how
do these people exist how how are these
people brain I want to know so we can
stop it from happening
[Laughter]
this man turns myung-kil oka came under
a wig you could have just flattened it
no oh my god how did they be not that's
so funny
three California man arrested for
illegal sale of avocados totaling more
than three hundred thousand K what the
hell there's like people getting
murdered y'all out here arresting
avocado dealers how do you sell illegal
avocados I'm sure there's some bad I
don't know I wouldn't buy I wouldn't
want to buy off market vegetables
is that weird oh my god they do this all
the time I've seen this in UK as well we
have to present more than our 12 ounces
18 ounces oh this is someone being
stupid
oh okay never mind then how's the 18
ounces 50 cent more 12 ounces because 6
plus 12 baby sometimes what they do is
they write 50% more but they never
really specify what it is that is 50%
more on yacht owners with priceless art
need to be aware of flying champagne
corks 30% of Americans are one missed
paycheck away from poverty cheese says
is that true because everyone lives on
credit in America a flying train could
be coming your way what flying trains
finally yes
oh my god ahh I share the roads with
these morons founders at the bottom of
my delivery receipt thank you to whoever
this was deliver instructions pretty
sure this is the vine guy that does
awesome impressions yeah you put that
you put that Thomas light light facepalm
Oh some delicious mango I sure love
mango flavor mango Cavuto flavors you
ever wanted to fight your past self
password hint you know it's bro you got
it Brooke
that's so funny China figures out a
process to farm caviar thus saving wild
surgeon from extension and make a
delicacy widely affordable to the masses
American press after China thirded into
sheep snack Caviar's at the risk of
losing its status of luxury good bear
who poor yeah what what is the downfall
of this Jesus Christ
you astound reject solar farm amend
whereas it would suck up all the energy
from the Sun damn nuclear reactor even
if it did suck up the energy I think
would be ok
how stupid soap opera can be better
check his pulse on his nose let's make
sure he looks as dead as possible it's
my future I want to be an engineer sex
can wait because one definitely has to
what are you what does he think of being
an engineer his anyway that's all the
time we have for today smash like
subscribe check out the merch apically
and I see you guys tomorrow bye bye bye
bye
[Music]
too long you have been farting in the
corner now you are entering a new era
where you shall crash they own
the hour of our spells and poop grades
is coming
marzia Edgar and buttons need you
the timer you will face but crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne booty is the game to play I'm not
supposed to have my opinion about that
but the prices
you